becomes what is a bigger problem is the
i have a feeling he's a crusade type of
guy i have a feeling he loves america
more than he loves florida is that a
pretty fair question to ask i don't
think you can say he loves florida
florida is america right now but i think
but but i think to me america is the
constitution america is the federalist
paper america is not florida is i think
i think to him if he's a crusader which
i believe he is i think he to him you
know
florida is a job that was up there for
him to take and he took it and he's done
a great job with it but i think for him
america
matters
more than florida does not saying that
florida's not important please don't
take it that way but it's kind of like
your kid and the wife
you love your kids but man you know this
thing was founded based on your wife
your family there's a certain lineage
out i think america is kind of
maybe again
selfishly i don't want him to run you
have to understand i'm here i don't want
the
uh you know
the the former governor that almost won
by thirty thousand only lost by thirty
thousand votes but i'm saying case wise
if he loves america more
america kind of is looking for someone
to want to run my only concern is the
face-off between him and trump how ugly
that's going to be that's why he asked
does he love america more than florida
again there's so much there's so many
real concrete things we could talk about
so i don't know that we need to keep
speculating about that
but um what i can say is florida is what
america should be florida is the ideals
that america was founded on which is
individual rights which is liberty which
is freedom which is protection from
government tyranny right we were founded
on a revolution against government
tyranny we've been a magnet for refugees
and i know you came here as a refugee so
from all over tyrannies all over the
world that came here for a better life
so it's like you know to say that to
choose between america and florida i
don't think it's really the right
framework i think you look at florida
under desantis as what america is was
and should be
but unfortunately some other states with
these more dictatorship type of policies
they are moving away from by the way
after this interview's over
everything you just said go back and
watch that because let me tell you
something
florida
never had that reputation of being the
bastion of freedom and being this place
where you know the whole country is
looking at as a case example florida has
been mocked
for decades of being like this like
sunny place for shady people florida man
florida man i'm sure we've got some
stories with that and this is what ron
desantis should run on whether it's in
22 or 24 or 28 is that i have changed
florida's reputation i've lived in
florida my whole life i've never heard
anybody address florida the way that you
just addressed florida as being this
the great hope of america it's it's like
i'm almost like proud but also laughing
on the inside i'm like did she really
just freaking say that about florida so
that is what ron de santa should run off
and i'm not the only one you know you
were just talking about all these people
moving here from new york from
california from new jersey from
connecticut from all these different
states and why are they moving here
it's because that's the feeling that
they have that's the impression they
have in florida i have a friend i dinner
with last night she's from brooklyn she
has little kids she was tired of them
eating on the concrete outside of school
because of the mask mandate and because
they had to eat lunch out there because
of covet now they're living a normal
life in boca
and they get to have a childhood and you
can't put a price on that you know like
that is something that just it is the
number one thing for most parents
wanting their kids to have a good life
and that this is what governor desantis
has given people from all over the
country this kind of hope you can run on
that that's for sure and i know pat has
beaten the dead horse with the trump
stuff but i'll give you a different
perspective and then i'm sure we can we
can move on he doesn't want desantis to
run
because of
you know every the great job he's done
in florida
i actually do
and i've been very open about this i do
not want to see trump again at all and
i'm a little disenfranchised with biden
full disclosure i voted for biden did
not want trump again but whether it's
age whether it's persona i think america
is ready for something new something
fresh something that can hopefully unify
the country that we can get around yeah
maybe you didn't like trump but this guy
is crushing florida and he's well he's
ready to be a unifier potentially so
that's what i think is what is drawing
this desantis into the national
you know picture so much is that there's
so much yearning out there just please
not trump again please let's get by now
there's so much of that and that's why
desantis like for instance in the cpac
poll trump at 55 the only person even
close was desantis so the media and just
normal people are latching on to someone
like desantis as like almost like
the great white hope so i know
obviously deflect it's all good he's not
running he has to focus on florida i'm
just like that's the reason why people
are like come on bro
that's
my perspective i mean i respect that i
respect your perspective but i just
this this whole conflict
doesn't exist right now it exists in in
some people's minds right
but
it's not materially real so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch or if you want to
see the entire podcast click over here
take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]